you have a look at these two questions
and this is what we call well they
really inform it to be this panel this
is called a sorting question okay this
is a sorting question so many times like
as a as an assessment setup we put
questions in just to see okay if you if
you have something like this if I just
say can you can you graph this please
can you graph this place what I'm
testing for is have you just haven't
done the work that is included in the
course because if you have then you'll
be able to do that with no sweat
you'll just there's my intercept there's
like shape etc okay this is a question
just to demonstrate a basic skill okay
between these two questions there is not
a basic skill there is a higher water
sort of understanding that I'm looking
for
okay now if you look at these two and
you think they're the same you have
demonstrated something right right
namely that you see this and yet freek
footbanf what what shape is that never
seen that before you have seen it before
it's a hyperbola but if you do not
distinguish between the difference
between them there's a higher skill
missing for example this is a different
question and when we have seen this
before so I have a vertical asymptote
here because because because I can't
divide by zero it's outside the domain
and then because why is this subject
right it's y is less than so it's a
vertical thing am I thinking up or my
thinking down I'm thinking down so down
yeah can't cross that asymptote right
and then over here the other branch
again down no problems and you can test
that points to confirm that okay hold on
hold on stay with mother now if we are
now to rephrase the question and use
this as our starting point okay to move
from here to here it's a really simple
question but just humor me
what operation have I done to both sides
of this inequality to go from live one
to line to answer
I divided by X I've divided this side by
X and I divided this side by X now you
guys know for instance if I asked you to
solve this right you would divide both
sides by minus one right so this would
become X but of course because you're
divided by a negative number right you
don't leave that inequality facing the
way it was before you turn it around
correct
now X is a variable it's not a number
it's variable sometimes is positive over
here it's positive but other times it's
going to be negative right X is negative
all over here so therefore when you do
this you do not get one result at the
end you get two you get a positive case
which by the way is exactly the same
right like when you have this yeah you
divide that by a positive number the
inequality is still facing in the same
direction okay so you're going to get
over here
you're going to get this just like you
got before it's underneath right but
when you come over to and I'm now
actually going to try it out the way we
should have written it and maybe if you
don't have space on your piece of paper
now or you don't have your piece of
paper in front of you okay so maybe get
out your fork
here's what you should have done here's
what you should have done I have two
cases I have a negative case and I have
a positive case right for the positive
case I just dealt with that the
inequality faces the same way but for
the negative case I'll still have the
same things but the inequality like this
guy has flipped around it's now greater
than I'm above the line okay so from
that I take it that I'm above up here
okay now you can go ahead and you can
test the point and you can verify that
in fact we're about to do that for the
last piece of information that I need to
put onto this graph which I didn't have
to worry about with this guy okay I have
an asymptote the boundary line is not
defined at x equals zero see you don't
need to worry about it
the region clearly will not be defined
if the boundaries not defined but have a
look at this guy no division by zero
right so I can put in X equal zero I can
put in y equal zero
I can put into this they were satisfied
is lying but this inequality like if you
put in x equals zero then zero times
anything will be zero right which sure
enough is less than six okay so in fact
every point along the y axis satisfies
the inequality so really my shading goes
right across it blows straight through
what you would think all as your
vertical asymptote over here which is
why it is not drawn so this is a real
curve ball isn't it right like you
wouldn't usually think to this because I
haven't shown you explicitly to do it
but I kind of wanted to see if you would
recognize that there really is a
difference between these namely this